[Music]
foreign
getting together
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
entire
welcome welcome
am I good all right
hello
hi
hi Merry Christmas
hola
welcome to the table welcome to
Christmas Eve at the table my name is
Karen Miner and uh we're gonna have
people slowly filling in
um but you guys are in your seat so
thank you thank you for being on time I
like it
and I think our musicians are still
filling in too
ah I'm so glad you're here welcome here
welcome to those of you who are watching
us online so glad you're joining us
tonight and a respite from the busyness
a respite from the cold
and we all get to be together
um I have just a couple of announcements
before we get started uh first of all
you might have noticed candles in your
seat we're going to use those at the end
of service you can go ahead and just put
those underneath your chairs and then
Brett will give you instructions on what
to do with them when he's done with his
message
secondly we will not be having service
tomorrow it's Christmas Day and we're
going to give all of our volunteers a
break to be able to rest and be with
their families and loved ones so no
service tomorrow if you do want to
attend a Christmas day service Pleasant
Valley will be having one right here
tomorrow morning at 9 00 a.m and they
are wonderful they're our extended
family they would love to have you so
that's tomorrow morning 9 A.M if you'd
like to attend a Christmas Day church
service and we will resume our normal
table Services the following Sunday
which will be New Year's Day at 5 pm
and we will be having our annual story
Sunday which if you have been here you
know how wonderful it is to hear from a
couple people in our community about
just how their lives been over the year
uh the way God's shown up in their lives
um and we would love to have you here
for that uh Sunday New Year's Day 5 p.m
right here for story Sunday
all right uh let's see
so
let's take a moment I know everybody's
just still kind of getting settled but
let's take a moment to really arrive
here right now
just allow yourself to sit and rest
go ahead and bow your heads close your
eyes
take a deep breath
quiet your mind
you're here now
so I'd like to invite you to really be
here now be present
let's pray
Jesus
you gave your all to the world in the
bleakness of that stable
love was born that day
pure undiluted love
poured out for all who call on your name
such Grace
undeserved
which deserves a response in the life
that we lead
draw us to this holy child
give us a new song to sing that will
resonate throughout this world
and begin with us this Christmas
amen
Eve is going to share with us a
scripture reading
in those days Caesar Augustus issued a
decree that census would be taken care
of the entire Roman world this was the
first census that took place while
coronius was governor of Syria and
everyone went to their own to register
so Joseph went up from the town of
Nazareth and Galilee to Judea to
Bethlehem the town of David because he
belonged to the house of and the line of
David
he went there to register with Mary who
was pledged to be married to him and was
expecting a child while they were there
the time came for the baby to be born
and she gave birth to her firstborn a
son she wrapped him in cloths and placed
him in a Manger because there was no
guest room available for them
foreign
[Music]
way to go
stranger
heavy heart is
longing for some
one you know
may you find the light
[Music]
please
may you find
underlying
light
may you find the light to guide you
[Music]
there are weary
Travelers
searching
everywhere you go
strangers
who are searching
[Music]
may you find the light
may you find alive
[Applause]
may you find the light to guide you
[Music]
may you find the light
may you find
me
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
guide us
to thy perfect
[Music]
please
may you find you
[Music]
may you find the right to guide you
JJ's gonna come and read for us now JJ
come on up
living out in the fields keeping watch
over their flocks at night an angel of
the Lord appeared to them in the glory
of the Lord Shone around them in they
were terrified
but the angel said to them do not be
afraid I bring good news that will cause
great joy for all the people
today in the town of David is born to
you a savior he is the Messiah the Lord
this will be assigned to you you will
find a baby wrapped up in cloths lying
in a Manger
missing Heart Of The Herald
thank you
Hark the Herald Angels see
glory to the newborn king
peace
[Music]
cut and sinners
reconciled
joyful ye nations
[Music]
join the Triumph of the sky
with
angelicals Proclaim
Christ is born in Bethlehem
heart the Herald Angels see
glory to the newborn
[Music]
foreign
Jesus
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
my only race
[Music]
glory to the
newborn king
Stella will you go ahead and come up and
read for us
[Music]
company of the heavenly host appeared
with the angel praising God and saying
glory to God in the highest heaven and
on Earth peace to those who roam his
favor rests
when the Angels had left them and gone
into heaven the shepherd said to one
another let's go to Bethlehem and see
this thing that has happened which the
Lord has told us about so they hurried
often found and Mary Joseph and the baby
who was lying in the manger when they
had seen him they spread the word
concerning what had
been told to them about this child and
all who heard it were amazed at what the
Sheep heard said to them
[Music]
[Laughter]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
glory to God
[Music]
here
cry
foreign
[Music]
adore him oh come let us
adore him
[Music]
the Lord
no come let us cry
foreign
[Music]
noelle's going to lead us in a way in a
Manger will you guys sing along
[Music]
the cattle are lowering the baby always
but little Lord Jesus
[Music]
look down from the sky
and stay by my cradle till morning
[Music]
foreign
away
[Music]
down his sweet head
the stars in the sky look down where he
lay
then O Lord Jesus
[Music]
Jesus thank you for the season that
reminds us
[Music]
that even when things are darkest
hope is near
thank you for light that breaks through
Darkness
thank you that you came fragile and
vulnerable
to save us
[Music]
God would we Embrace that same
vulnerability tonight
would we authentically open our hearts
children
[Music]
and receive the love that only you can
give
it's in Jesus name we pray
amen would you guys turn to the people
around you make them feel welcome and
then Brett will get us started with the
message
all right Merry Christmas everyone and
if you have any spaces be sure to push
towards the middle so we leave maybe a
seat or two on the edge if there are any
I don't know if there are
um well Merry Christmas it's so good to
be with you all and as always that
includes those joining us online you are
not forgotten love you a lot and uh and
especially anyone here who is new
um thank you for being uh being Among Us
on this um Christmas Eve it's a it's a
special day to come together to to
worship and to just re-center on Christ
it can be such a crazy season like do
you feel a little bit like oh my gosh we
made it like just the last few weeks and
all of the gifts and all of the things
and then just be here it's uh man it's
wonderful it's wonderful so
um the title of my my message this
Christmas Eve is Holy things in Unholy
places holy things in Unholy places and
um actually before we do our little
scripture reading
um I want to give a shout out to Eve and
Jeremiah and Stella for reading the
Christmas story so beautifully can y'all
give them a hand
they did they did wonderfully I thought
they did a little run through earlier
and I knew I was like oh my gosh this is
going to be great and uh and way to go a
special shout out to Stella for getting
up here that takes a lot of Courage when
you're as young as their next card for
anyone
um so y'all did a wonderful wonderful
job so um the text I want to go back and
reread a little bit of just three verses
it's from Luke 2 uh verses six through
eight
and it says this while they were there
that is Mary Joseph the time came for
the baby to be born
and she gave birth to her firstborn a
son she wrapped him in cloths and placed
him in a Manger because there was no
guest room available for them and there
were shepherds living out in the fields
nearby keeping watch over their flocks
at night
so Christmas
is the the coming of Christ into the
world and it announces that the holy
which is is really that which is of god
that which is dripping with goodness and
beauty and truth that that the holy has
entered into our world
a world that I think you'll agree is so
often while there's Beauty and and
things that can happen like it can be I
mean creation is wonderful and marvelous
um but so often the world can also be uh
not holy not dripping with goodness
Beauty and Truth um our world especially
Human Society can be so often marked by
by Lies by hatred by violence
relational conflict and breakdown
but Christmas announces that the holy
has entered into that world
and then rendered it
whole again
and that's incredibly good news which is
why Christmas is about the story of holy
things in Unholy places
when I was about eight years old
I remember
I had a strange experience because well
you know normally we expect holy things
to be in holy places not in Unholy
places right and so I remember I was
eight years old and I went to my first
rich person's house
and I know of course this is all
relative right just depends on your
level and then what rich I mean it's all
relative but at least for me
um I mean I just we it was our first
time we had a friend and uh he was a
chiropractor wow he was really just in
those spines well because this place was
I remember we pulled up and of course it
was like the um you know the gate and
then like the little intercom system
that you have to like roll down your
window and like push like hello yes
um yes the poor people were here to
visit you know like they're like okay
come on in the gate magically opens here
and remember we're going down this
driveway I mean this long winding
driveway a lake on the left acres and
acres and acres of land I mean it was
like gorgeous and then we pull up and
there it is like the Mansion it was so
fancy I remember we like we walked in
the front door and I honestly I just
kind of froze
because I well a it was like the just
the biggest space I'd ever seen in a
house we were just like oh my gosh this
living room is gigantic uh but the
second reason I froze is because
everything
and I mean everything in this house
was white
like I mean taken to an extreme I don't
mean like most things no I mean like
white carpet White Walls of course white
snailing uh Furniture I mean white
couches and side tables and we go in the
kitchen it's the fridge and the marble
uh countertop and the I mean every
picture frame ever I mean everything in
this house was what I remember I walked
in as like a little you know
eight-year-old boy and I'm like oh gosh
oh no
I don't can I can we come in here are
you allowed to walk on your carpet can
we go I mean it looks like a model home
except people actually lived in this
model home you know like it was that
kind of place and I did I just had this
sense of like uncomfortableness in that
house because
um well it was like holy so to speak you
know like it was sort of pristine and
perfect and I just had this sense of
like oh no this is not the place for me
I should probably stay outside
now I want you to have that kind of
image of little eight-year-old Brett
kind of with trepidation going into that
house and now in your mind's eye though
at the same time I also want you to
start to see the first Christmas
and and here's the question uh
call to mind where Christ was born
I mean he's the Lord of all creation so
you might expect like only a fine
mention of white you know would do or
maybe a palace or I mean at least like a
religious holy place you're like a
temple but of course you will know like
where was Christ actually born
yeah a stable a barn and then yes and
what was his first resting place
someone said it over here
a Manger that's right Jack it's a it was
a major and who knows what a Manger is
it's like it's one of those weird things
in the Bible that people it's something
like that yeah well it was basically it
was an animal feeding trough
so they would put they would put you
know oats or whatever the animal was
eating in there and and this was
Christ's first resting place
I mean this is this not telling us
something about who God is
I mean in other words it seems that God
does not shy away from the messiness of
the world
which also means that God does not shy
away from the messiness in our lives so
here's the question I want you to ponder
is there a place
in your own life
maybe it's a part of your story maybe
it's an ongoing like struggle or
addiction or just a shortcoming
something maybe it's even a secret and
you do your best to like let that be you
know not known to others
um but but is there sometimes a sense in
your own heart and mind of like oh no no
no no God God wouldn't really want
anything to do with me because of that
place
right like that struggle but but here's
the truth and this is the truth that
Christmas announces like it's completely
the opposite it's precisely in our
broken places that God meets us
right Christmas is all about holy things
in Unholy places or at least places that
we certainly think of as Unholy
unacceptable
um and like not Measuring Up
uh but maybe for you it's less about
like a specific place you know like an
aspect of your life maybe it's more of
just you as like a person
maybe you feel like there are like other
people are the holy people
you don't have to raise your hand but
anyone ever thought that kind of thing
you know like I just other they are the
holy people and I am not other people
they have their life together but I do
not and and so maybe for you it's it's
not so much just a place or an aspect of
your life maybe it's more about identity
you just have the sense of like maybe
not measure enough
or or maybe it's even just a sense of
like being just a regular person you're
like I there's just nothing
extraordinary uh about me like at all
um but here's the truth
Christmas is not only about holy things
and Unholy places
Christmas is also about holy things in
ordinary people
again uh coming back to our
um our our Christmas story if you will
recall to mind uh who was there on the
night of Christ's birth
um again it's sort of different than who
we might think you know we would think I
don't know like if it were in our own
day it would be like all of the amazing
people like all of the famous people you
know all the Instagram influencers would
be like showing up for maybe a selfie
with Jesus or something you know like
this we would just expect all of maybe
the one percent or at the very least we
might expect like the religious Elites
you know surely it's the birth of Christ
like I mean so so maybe a priest or like
a bishop or two but but no like who was
actually there on the night of Christ's
birth you recall it was his his to his
peasant parents Mary and Joseph and then
who was it that the Angels announced the
birth of this holy child to kids anyone
we read it Shepherds
it was the Shepherds verse 8 and there
were shepherds living out in the fields
nearby now in case you're wondering uh
shepherding was not a prestigious
position
this was uh it was something mostly like
teenagers did for their parents
and it would be almost like uh in our
own day like if the Christmas story said
and the angels appeared to all of the
the sonic Bell Hops and Saxy Texas work
in the midnight shift on Christmas Eve
you know like it's it would be like it
would be something like that
um in other words not like the the rich
and the powerful but this is this is
often how we think though we think well
those people are acceptable people God
we we think God only cares about
Extraordinary People amazing people but
like not about me but but that's just
the thing
hey God he was born he lived he died he
rose again like for you four Ordinary
People Christmas is about holy things in
ordinary people
uh but maybe for you this Christmas
maybe it's less about like an aspect of
your life
um that you find kind of unacceptable or
you as a whole that you feel too like
ordinary or something uh maybe for you
this Christmas it's simply that there
are well that maybe this was like one of
the most difficult
seasons one of the most difficult years
in your life
and
you and it's it's led to a sense or a
feeling of like distance from God
but I want to invite you all to do right
now is Just Close Your Eyes For a Moment
and I want you to kind of see your year
in review
and specifically I want you to call to
mind some of the difficult circumstances
that you've faced this year
maybe it was illness
or someone you love deeply who was ill
maybe it was relational breakdown
school work struggles
job loss
someone you love passing away
all right you can go ahead and open your
eyes
here's God's word to you this Christmas
is about holy things in painful
circumstances
you see the tendency is to say
well God is with me in the good times
amen
right like it's like yes like when
things are going well then Christ is
present
Hallelujah you know as we if you were
here a few weeks ago we talked about uh
the Twitter hashtag blessed and highly
favored which people are very fond of
and you know it's this idea of like when
everything in my life is going great
then I am blessed and highly favored but
what happens is this begs the question
yeah but then what about when things
aren't so great right like like when
what about when things start getting
messy in our lives
but but that's the beautiful thing
um Christ is present with us there
Christmas is about holy things in
painful circumstances uh now you might
ask where do we see this in like the
first Christmas Story I mean I'm
thinking you know Christmas is it's so
happy right the first cruise you got
Mary and Joseph their cute little baby
and there we see the Shepherds probably
you know leaning on their staffs it's
just all idyllic and very precious
moments you know uh but uh we'll
consider this verse 7.
says and she gave birth
to her firstborn a son
have you stopped to consider that Christ
was born
like literally born like actual birth
have you ever been to a birth
I mean well I guess all of you have you
know but you know what I mean like uh
I've been to three wow oh my gosh I mean
talk about like pain challenge difficult
I won't go into any details I want to
get you know too graphic but it's just
it's a lot right can I get a name in
ladies like it's just it's a lot
right and
and so I think in a ways isn't like that
a picture of Christ's whole life though
like almost like a picture of who he
would be I think of the prophet Isaiah
who said that that Christ would be a man
of Sorrows acquainted with grief that he
would bear our suffering that he would
um take on our struggles and our our
sins and our shame
and and I think
it's such a picture like the fact that
Christ was actually born in pain in
struggle that he really did enter into
the human situation with us
and so here's kind of what I'm driving
at do you know this Christmas
that in every painful moment God is with
you if you don't hear anything else
tonight please hear this
do you know this Christmas that in every
single painful moment of your life
that's not the moment when God's like oh
whoa okay I didn't foresee this kind of
masking off it no do you know in every
painful moment that God is with you God
has not abandoned you in your chronic
illness God has not abandoned you in
your relational breakdown in your
schoolwork struggles
in your job loss
God is with you even in the vehicle
you're not even sure it will make it to
the new year God is with you
see Christmas is about holy things in
Unholy places holy things and Ordinary
People and holy things in painful
circumstances
will you bow your heads and close your
eyes
I want to go ahead and pray over us
Lord Jesus
we thank you that you in all of your
beauty and wonder and holiness
you are not cold
you're not remote
or removed
rather you are Emmanuel God With Us
and may that promise give us joy
May that promise make a smile again this
Christmas
May that promise give us hope
in the name of the Christ
who was born lived
died
rose again innocent
amen
well
we come to that moment that at least all
of the kids have been waiting for
fire Jack says the fire
the fire of God
um we are gonna light our candles so if
you want to grab that and the ushers
also have some extras if anyone maybe
doesn't have one uh Jeff and and my dad
Greg he'll they'll kind of walk those
down the aisle just in case anyone needs
one so the way we're gonna go about this
is uh
they're going to go ahead and in just a
moment once we start the music they'll
they're going to light the candles but
we are going to need you to kind of turn
to your neighbor and you know light
their candle
um but one really key thing in that is
if your candle is already lit
I would rather you not be the person to
turn yours sideways because then the wax
starts to you know dripping off onto
everything so let your neighbor let the
person without their candle lit let them
be the first person to you know kind of
turn their candles sideways to to get
the the lights
um also if you are with us online we'd
love for you to participate in this
moment with us maybe you know grab a
candle or two from your living room or
wherever you have them and uh and join
in and with us in this time
so this Christmas
May the light
that you're about to hold
may it be a picture of the light of God
of the light of love
of peace
of joy of Hope of everything
that you need that I need that our world
needs
and then as we like those candles may it
be a picture of that light of God in
love and peace and joy and hope maybe a
picture of it spreading
and then may it go with us
out into this hurting world
and may we bring the light and love of
God into that place
Merry Christmas
[Music]
foreign
under my
[Music]
sleep in
Heavenly peace
[Music]
you guys sing this with us
sir
[Music]
oh
holy nights pure
[Music]
breathing in peace
foreign
[Music]
Holy Night
s
[Music]
okay
oh singing
Christ
[Music]
foreign
thanks so much for being with us tonight
[Music]
you can go ahead and blow out your
candles
but go ahead and hold on to them
and don't put them on the ground yet or
on your seat we don't want to get wax on
the floor on the chairs we want to be
good to our hosts good to Pleasant
Valley because they're going to be in
here a little later tonight
um
[Music]
foreign and when you're dismissed take
your candle with you and we'll have
ushers by the back door where you can
drop your candles in there on the way
out
um
thank you so much for being here tonight
your presence here and those of you
online just enriches our community we
wouldn't be the same without you here so
thank you so much for being here tonight
if you were visiting with us if this has
been your first time here please on your
way out as you go out the back door
there's a little itty bitty wood table
with a box if you could write your name
on one of the cards that has the table
on there write your name your contact
information drop it in that box on your
way out we would love to be able to
contact you just to say thank you for
being here tonight and have a record
that you were with us
um
and then lastly I would love to send you
out with a benediction so if you are
comfortable doing so please rise to your
feet
[Music]
may you leave with the joyous sounds of
Christmas in your ears
a vision of the savior in your mind the
spirit of the season in your memory
the joy of the season in your life
the faith of the Christ child in your
soul and the message of the season on
your lips
and may you know that you know
I want to make eye contact with every
one of you may you know that you know
that you know that you know how very
very much you're loved Merry Christmas
be blessed and we hope to see you back
here not tomorrow but next Sunday for
story Sunday good night
one two three
may you find life
[Music]
may you find the light to guide you home
[Applause]
[Music]
may you play
may you fly
[Music]
to guide you
[Applause]
[Music]